das ist wirklich eine spektakuläre
behauptung des us insektenforschers
william rose er ist sich sicher auf
bildern verschiedener mars missionen
nicht nur fossilien sondern sogar
lebende maß insekten identifiziert zu
haben
doch nicht nur das der wissenschaftler
ist außerdem überzeugt davon dass
höheres leben auf dem mars existiert
doch habe man ist bislang schlichtweg
übersehen okay was ist dran an dieser
verrückten story kriegs und science
fiction hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
er nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
es sind nicht nur fossilen sondern sogar
lebende tiere die der us
insektenforscher william rohrmoser
entdeckt haben will und zwar auf
aufnahmen vom mast heißt also der
wissenschaftler ist überzeugt davon dass
es nicht nur leben auf dem roten
planeten gegeben haben muss sondern
höhere lebensformen sogar noch heute auf
dem mars zu finden sind sie tat es gab
und gibt immer noch leben auf dem mars
und das ist keineswegs als schlechter
scherz gemeint rohrmoser meint es völlig
ernst nicht umsonst hat der us
insektenforscher diese behauptungen auf
dem jahreskongress der american
entomologie society in san luis
vorgestellt mit dabei auch die
entsprechenden bilder auf denen er
angeblich die mars insekten aufgespürt
haben will zu sehen sind mehr oder
weniger verwaschene strukturen die roma
aber nicht als felsbrocken oder
gesteinsformationen interpretiert
sondern als fossilien
er spricht von mehreren fotos auf denen
ganz eindeutig ein segmentierte
hinterleib und der thorax also das
segment zwischen kopf und hinterleib zu
sehen sind diese anatomischen
charakteristisch seien beweis genug für
seine behauptung dazu will dem rosa eine
gliederung in drei körperregionen
einfach antennen und sechs beine sind
traditionell ausreichen um auf der erde
ein insekt zu identifizieren auf dieser
basis sind insekten ähnliche antipoden
auch in den fotos der mars-rover
sichtbar
doch damit nicht genug auf den mars
rover fotos seien außerdem auch lebende
tiere zu erkennen eine schwere
interpretiert rom moser als tier im
sturzflug das kurz vor dem aufschlag
wieder hochziehen
außerdem will er eine art bienenstock
aufgespürt haben und eines der fotos
zeigt rosa zufolge sogar den kopf einer
schlange doch nicht nur tiere möchte der
insektenforscher auf dem mars aufgespürt
haben sondern sogar auch kleinen tümpel
mit flüssigem wasser wow das klingt
alles ziemlich verrückt dabei ist will
im rosa gar nicht irgendwer er hat sich
viele jahrzehnte ausschließlich mit
insekten beschäftigt und hat auch ein
sehr bekanntes lehrbuch zu diesem thema
verfasst dennoch kommen seine
interpretationen in der fachwelt gar
nicht gut an demnach entbehren seine
entdeckung jeder wissenschaftlichen
grundlage die vermeintlichen insekten
seien gewöhnliche gesteinsbrocken da ist
sich die fachwelt sichert die rede ist
von einer partei dolly also eine art
trugschluss dem rosa darauf gesessen sei
konkret ist damit das phänomen gemeint
in mustern und gegen vertraute
gegenstände wesen oder gesichter zu
erkennen obwohl diese eben gar nicht
vorhanden sind und genau diesem phänomen
sind auch schon andere leute forum mose
aufgesessen und das ebenfalls auf dem
mars als location die rede ist vom
sogenannten mass gesicht das 1976 auf
einer aufnahme der sonde viking 1
aufgespürt wurde eine struktur in der
donauregion sah von oben betrachtet aus
wie ein gesicht mit nase mund und augen
doch es handelte sich um eine optische
täuschung denn dahinter steckt eine
gewöhnliche gesteinsformation auf die
durch den tiefen sonnenstand schatten
gefallen waren
so glich die formation dann also einem
menschlichen gesicht kurios denn so
erlangt tatsächlich eine ganz
gewöhnliche gesteinsformation weltraum
heißt also im klartext auch wenn william
rohrmoser sehr von seiner eigenen
theorie überzeugt ist ist diese nicht
besonders glaubwürdig und realistisch
denn trotz intensiver forschung gibt es
bisher keine hinweise darauf dass der
mars höheres leben beherbergt auf dem
roten planeten fehlt es an wasser und
auch die atmosphäre ist alles andere als
freundlich dennoch ist nicht nur die
nasa mit hochdruck dabei nach
lebensformen auf dem mars zu suchen im
visier der fachleute stehen dabei aber
eher mikroorganismen die vielleicht
sogar in der vergangenheit von planet zu
planet gelangt sind einfachste
organismen oder bausteine des lebens
könnten durch einen sogenannten
interplanetaren transport durch
meteoriteneinschläge von planet a auf b
gelangt sein
bei allen uneinigkeiten ist sich die
fachwelt allerdings in einem punkt mit
william rose einig weitere untersuchung
des mars sind unbedingt angebracht kommt
das leben
aus dem all anklicken anschauen und
heute mal diesen kanal ihr kriegs um
science-fiction abonnieren dafür spricht
einfach alles ist es nämlich kostenlos
also abo button unbedingt anklicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran